pour le second tour des municipales à
villepreux trois listes seront en lice
celle menée par jean baptiste à monique
arrivés en tête lors du premier tour
valérie ben mènera la liste agir tous
pour villepreux issu de la fusion avec
la liste de sylvie ce vin montel enfin
le maire sortant stéphane mirambeau
était arrivé le 15 mars dernier en
troisième position avec ses onze mille
habitants gilles preuve fait partie de
saint quentin en yvelines depuis 2016 et
devrait compter un nouveau quartier à
l'horizon 2025
après plusieurs mois de concertation le
projet central park avait été dévoilée
fin 2018
objectif créer une entrée de ville
urbaine et paysagère scénario choisi 250
logements et un grand parc urbain de 19
mille mètres carrés plusieurs candidats
souhaitent que ce projet soit gelée
autre thème qui s'invite dans la
campagne la santé ville prenez pas un
désert médical mais situé dans une zone
d'action complémentaires selon la rs
l'offre de soins est jugée insuffisante
et pourrait être étoffée avec la
création d'une maison de santé
autre enjeu la redynamisation du centre
ville et notamment le développement des
commerces de proximité qui souffrent de
la concurrence des zones commerciales
des villes voisines de plaisir et des
clayes-sous-bois enfin quel avenir pour
le théâtre de villepreux l'établissement
culturel de 400 places ne propose plus
de spectacle depuis septembre dernier
plusieurs candidats souhaitent re
développer la culture dans la ville et
réhabiliter cet espace